as Donald Trump thrashed out at Frances
president Mac on this week on Twitter
he also took aim at what he saw as
unfair trade practices when it comes to
wine tariffs where says sir said the
French who are very precious about their
wine the Donald said both countries made
excellent wine but France made it very
hard for the u.s. to sell its wines to
the country and charges big tariffs so
that got us thinking who makes the
better wine the US or France it's time
for battle of the new world wine versus
the old and the judges it's the
Parisians Capote beaker and the vaults
for sale Amir Volker Levon Africa a week
to the Holocaust where Chris Cole was
Jesus did not fulfill a news article
also say come here
ah say a boo boo boo boo taco to be
close
but only big Sinopec actually more
sellable no decisions don't live in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
America mr. Compton is at home for that
Buffalo corset for C so the verdict is
in and it's pretty clear
Parisians preferred the wine from the us
Kel or her well maybe for once the
Donald has been vindicated as the wine
from his country seems to have Trump
that from France so on this occasion
from Paris
we admit defeat but nevertheless we will
always raise a glass and say Sante
Charlotte dibinsky RT Paris
you